damage estimates from Northern
California's deadly wildfires top 3
billion dollars and that number is
expected to grow the wineries were hit
hard more than 30 were destroyed or
damaged after the fires broke out early
last week Adriana Diaz as it is at
ancient oak cellars winery that's in
Santa Rosa which suffered extensive
damage Adriana good morning good morning
California wine making is a 58 a billion
dollar industry and now some of that
could go up in smoke
as you can see here a wild fire ripped
through this winery destroying this work
truck and the vines behind it we got a
look at the destruction from the air in
a California National Guard helicopter
the wind-driven firestorm burned entire
neighborhoods to the ground also
destroyed huge expanses of vineyards
this was the house Ken Moho t-bird and
his wife owned the ancient oak cellars
winery in Santa Rosa they not only lost
the home his grandfather built but part
of their vineyard and mow Holtz ebert
says the prime time to harvest the
surviving grapes was last week but
closed roads kept him away from his
property there a little past when I
would like to have want to pick them you
start to see them shrink a little bit
and that's a loss of weight and that
counts on the bottom line mold Seibert
could face not only a loss of income but
major expenses as well things like
ripping up the soil and replacing
irrigation systems even grapes untouched
by the flames could be tainted by smoke
affecting dozens of wineries I would say
there's probably 30 to 60 that have been
heavily impacted Louis Purdue was a wine
industry analyst is that a large
percentage of the amount of vineyards
out here well you have to realize there
are somewhere close to 900 wineries and
in Napa and Sonoma so it's serious but
it's not a killer blow to the industry
if there's any silver lining here it's
that 90% of the grapes in Napa were
already harvested before the fires broke
out the wine tourism industry those are
the tasting rooms the hotels that tour
bus companies want people to know that
most of wine country is still open Jeff
Adriana thank you very much